[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
Наливочку пили, настрій є,
гайда співати з музиками!
♪ [грають народну музику] ♪
[Карпати,
Вигода]
♪ [грають народну музику] ♪
Ану дівчатка, приєднуйтесь,
піднімаємо гарний настрій, співаємо!
Люди сюди приїжджають і
ми їм хочемо розказати про історичну спадщину.
Щоб вони побачили оці краєвиди
і щоб вони відчули, що це душа наша,
душа Карпат — ми хочемо показати,
що вона унікальна.
[Любомир Яцків
Керівник проєкту «Карпатський трамвай»]
♪ [грають народну музику] ♪
У 2003 році ми святкували п'ятий
Всесвітній бойківський фестиваль,
який проходив на наших теренах:
в Долині, Калуші і Болехові.
Хотілося зробити щось особливе,
адже з'їдуться бойки із цілого світу.
Чим їх здивувати?
І ми взяли один вагончик,
паровозик — зробили екскурсію.
Усім сподобалося!
Після цього ми потроху
почали налагоджувати роботу.
Тут нічого не було.
Ми підписали такий меморандум
між румунською, польською,
австрійською і чеською
вузькоколійними залізницями.
Вони приїжджають до нас, а ми до них.
Останнім часом до нас приїздять також
білоруси, австрійці, поляки, німці.
Так ми розповідаємо
про наш бойківський край цілій Європі.
Історія нашої вузькоколійки
сягає другої половини 19 століття.
Барон Поппер сюди приїхав простим інженером.
Але він через 8-10 років розбагатів. У чому річ?
Він придбав дуже багато земельних ділянок,
рубав ліс і відправляв до Європи.
Треба було переправляти якось ліс,
а вузькоколійки не було.
Тому він  переправляв його річками,
що ми бачимо, Свіча і Мизунка.
Але так було не довго.
Це тривало до 1939 року,
коли об'єднали західні і східні області України,
вузькоколійка перейшла у власність держави.
Держава продовжила
експлуатувати вузькоколійну залізницю
для вивезення деревини.
Згодом вона відійшла на другий план.
Від 1970-1980 років її почали розбирати.
А коли наша економіка впала до нуля,
почали платити зарплату оцими шпалами, рейками
вагонами і маленькими дрезинами.
Вона [вузькоколійка] повністю розпалася.
Коли, у 2000 році,  прийшло товариство
«Уніплит» на наші терени,
було 7 кілометрів готової до експлуатації колії.
Вони відновили 75 кілометрів
вузькоколійної залізниці
і почали займатися виробництвом.
Наші власники вузькоколійки мріють,
щоб поставити оцей поїзд на колію,
і він їхатиме, як колись, років 60-80 тому.
Для туризму це буде сильна атракція.
Ви можете собі уявити?
Я був у Польщі і бачив подібний поїзд.
Як він задимів я мав все лице чорне.
Як не дивно, всі хочуть цього задоволення.
Це було б гарним видовищем,
якби ми його поставили.
Ви, напевне, бачили, коли ми щойно проїжджали,
що ми «Мерседес» поставили на колію?
А ще в нас є маленьке таксі,
тому, якщо щось станеться —
можна подзвонити і воно швидко приїде.
Жарти жартами, але три чи чотири роки
ми робили фестиваль екстремальних
видів спорту «Мізунська Zвигода» .
На велосипедах.
Отам, де ми проїжджали.
Що вони там виробляли, ви б бачили.
Це було присвячено до свята Івана Купала.
Цілими днями ми організовували фестиваль,
а на ніч до нас приїжджали рок-гурти.
Дійшло до того, що люди зі села сказали:
«Не треба нам тих фестивалів,
бо корови перестали доїтися.
Вони вночі слухають музику і не дають молока».
Розумієте в чому річ?
Коли я працював на державній роботі,
я відповідав за туризм.
Згодом я зрозумів, що там можна відповідати,
а тут можна творити.
Тому я пішов творити туризм.
Мої друзі говорять, що я трішки смішний,
що пішов на таку роботу.
Але я задоволений.
Мені вже стільки років,
а я все працюю і бігаю.
Зараз вже легше, адже в мене є заміна.
Є люди, які разом зі мною
працюють і підтримують мене.
Вони хочуть це робити.
Я кажу Олежику, що вже не буду
весь час займатися.
Ти будеш начальником поїзда. І йому сподобалося.
Річка, природа і гарні туристи.
Моя дружина Дарійка колись мені казала:
«Що ти, де ти йдеш?
Це є фантастика.
Де ти можеш таке зробити?»
А тепер каже: «Не вірила, але вийшло!»
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олександр Портян]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Марія Теребус]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Музика
Крапки-Коми, Патроничі]
[Субтитрувальник
Владислав Цовма]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]